she said she doesn't care about it
somebody just walked down oh look who
just walked in
yeah we are but that's okay it's not
really live that's logan that's your
brother-in-law it's my my
ex-brother-in-law and my brother for the
rest of my life oh my god i love more
than that they're gonna [ __ ] on the
couch oh my god
no you're not supposed to that would
make us vomit
how do you guys still get along and you
don't get a little first of all before
this is a [ __ ] idiot who [ __ ] up my
life this is logan paul and if you read
his shirt prime is the new drink that he
is just
right oh you're trying to get the wrong
way i'm drinking the wrong drink
him and here here throw it to me no wait
i want to do it i want to sell it yeah
whoa throw it to me this is your new
drink prime
and you and ksi right yeah yeah are
launching this together this is going to
be you want did you want one ksi's doing
amazon something i'll take one you guys
are here no take one
i'll have one yeah
it's it's so it's a hydration beverage
it's uh it's focused on can i ask you
something isn't every beverage a
hydration beverage
[Laughter]
but no no no no coffee coffee is not i
mean with all the black you know i
passed out from being dehydrated i saw
that on the news howie are you okay
yeah
zoom in
zoom in
damn i feel like you need a pass out
scandal with tana oh my god i know why
have i done everything but pass out you
should consider fainting in public he's
like i actually do think you should
overdose soon
i'm just joking it's absolutely
[Music]